en esta primera audiencia se tratarán de
responder seis preguntas la primera de
ellas será cuánta responsabilidad tiene
rompe en los actos violentos la segunda
es como trump uso herramientas políticas
para poderse quedar en el poder también
se trataba de responder como tanta gente
creyó el tema de las mentiras
electorales que durante la campaña
pasada a la presidencia trump trató de
meterle a la gente en la cabeza la
cuarta pregunta es si hay conexión entre
lo que hicieron los oficiales de la
policía carol washington y también
oficiales políticos con la violencia de
las personas la quinta es porque el
capitolio estaba tan poco protegido y la
sexta es que se va a hacer para evitar
este tipo de cosas en la audiencia de
hoy lo que se va a hacer principalmente
será presentar precisamente lo que la
investigación ha llevado las pruebas que
tiene este comité de casey durante un
año ha investigado y ha hecho más de
1000 entrevistas como se mencionaba
cristóbal de cómo es la seguridad en el
capitolio y cuántas audiencias se espera
que haya frente al caso
si la seguridad es bastante fuerte no
solamente en el capitolio sino en toda
la ciudad los policías están trabajando
horas extras precisamente porque al
frente del capitolio está la corte
suprema y en las próximas semanas se
conocerá también la decisión sobre el
aborto esto ha llevado a muchas
protestas donald trump también ha
invitado a sus seguidores a pues salir y
manifestar su apoyo para defender su
partido para defender su proyecto
político es hay que resaltar que este
esperan que sean hasta ocho audiencias
en junio y se espera también una
audiencia en septiembre justo antes de
las elecciones electorales de
legislativas en noviembre es de
mencionar también que todos los canales
principales empezarán a transmitir
la presentación de hoy en el congreso a
partir de las 77 y media y cuando
empiece ya oficialmente estas audiencias
a las 8 de la noche hora de washington
el único canal que no presentará estas
audiencias será boxing